should
chris rock forgive
uh will smith
for a pilot for embarrassing like that
and smacking him in front of the world
news from the academy what they're now
saying about actor will smith
after that stunning moment at the oscars
you holding a grudge
is like drinking poison hoping the other
person dies so every time you know
someone annoyed you you put it in that
bag a grudge in that bag it becomes so
heavy but the majority
it's not justifiable for people to cut
off you have so many studies also
psychologists psychiatrists talk about
you know this being a detriment to your
health yeah allah i forgive that person
so ya allah would you forgive me bismil
alhamdulillah assalamu alaikum greetings
or peace welcome to another episode of
the dean show now my next guest
sheikh majid mahmood is not only a
mechanical engineer but he also has a
bachelor in islamic juris prudence from
medina international university a
masters in business administration
and he is here with us
to not talk about business
to not talk about engineering but to
talk about the dean forgiveness
particularly because it's the month of
mercy the month
of ramadan
how are you doing
pretty good alhamdulillah how about
yourself
good good how's everything there in
detroit
yes sir i've handled everything as well
how's ramadan so far with you so far so
good alhamdulillah
you have a video that really affected a
lot of people's lives
you know for the positive you know
people who watch this
it was labeled forgive and forget so
some people weren't forgiven and they
weren't forgetting but they watched this
video and they were able to do both
do you remember this video
yes yes
tell us a little bit about it what are
some of the things that you talked about
in there and the importance and the
importance you know how this connects
with islam the importance importance of
this topic forgiveness and letting
things go
absolutely absolutely
you know when it comes to forgiveness
islam is very very very big on it
so much so
that allah
he tells people a formula he says would
you not want god to forgive you
so for you to get god's forgiveness
there's multiple ways there's me asking
for forgiveness
there's me giving in charity
uh there is me going for hajj right
but one of the easiest and fastest and
strongest ways to get allah's
forgiveness is when we forgive others
subhanallah so that's the deal allah has
even revealed a verse regarding it so
forgiving is something very healthy to
our own selves i'm not telling people to
be selfish but when you think of
forgiveness think about yourself don't
worry about the other person think about
you
forgetting sometimes it works sometimes
doesn't work but when you forgive and
you don't put so much attention to the
topic it helps you forget
because if you have that grudge and you
continue to talk about it you continue
to text about it you continue to bring
this topic up in every gathering it will
be very difficult for you to forget may
allah make it easier for all of us so
forgiveness definitely
uh let's go ahead and give some real
examples i don't know if you uh have
some stories to share something that was
in the in the news so if i ask you
should and this is just to hit home like
a real example now and if these two
were to accept islam let's say they were
muslim or whatnot
and should
chris rock forgive
uh will smith
for a pilot for embarrassing me like
that and smacking him in front of the
world
yes that's a very good question you know
in islam alhamdulillah we have multiple
options
so
we know an eye for an eye so if chris
would like to slap wool back you know
that's an option
right
the the other one in islam option two is
that i don't want anything from the
other person today you know will i
forgive you and not forgive me sorry i
will let you go i will not file a
lawsuit against you
i will not file criminal charges against
you
but i want to meet you on a day of
judgment where i will take your good
deeds so that's option two
option three you don't slap back
you do not wait to meet will on the day
of judgement but the third one would be
i don't want anything from the other
side
i want only from allah but how does that
make sense
allah
for the third and that's for the elite
may allah make us all of the elite
number three the our people
allah says whoever forgives
and reconcile their reward is on allah
so allah keeping it open like that
indicates what indicates
that the reward is unmatched and it will
be equivalent to the greatness of the
king so i'll give an example
if chris is being told chris i promise
yeah chris rock some being told chris i
promise
we will give you a deal
that you will never reject
now who's saying that let's say a very
famous act like will or whatever or the
whole academy so chris will know that
whatever check i will get is equivalent
to the wealth the other person has
correct yeah
so here allah is the best of examples he
tells you if you forgive i will take
care of you and when allah the king of
all kings says i'll take care of you
then he will take care of you
subhanallah because in dunya brother
eddie sometimes people say i don't care
how much they pay me right yeah i will
never forgive but with allah there is a
payment that you will be able to forgive
let's go a little bit deeper in there
because now people can go ahead and try
to equate that with some kind of drama
or some kind of pain suffering that
they're going through in life but okay
so this is a real situation that
happened where you have will smith and
then smacking chris rock in front of the
world so now his options according to
islam is that he can
uh in front of everybody now get smacked
the same way
everyone
so
smack will smith could smack him back if
he allowed it right yeah yeah and the
second one what was the second one again
the second one is that i want to meet
you on a day of judgment yeah
and take equivalent to the smack in good
deeds
okay so then but did he forgive him for
that or he's
that's
like it's like postponing it postponing
it okay and then the third one is just
like he didn't even apologize or
anything and he just lets it go and then
he expects his reward from god almighty
allah
yes and obviously it would be better to
verbalize that uh if oh if the other
person is saying will in this situation
no uh forget will chris rock yeah he can
ignore will for example if you know what
i don't want anything from this guy i
don't want to talk about this situation
i'm past this moment and i want the
reward from allah subhanahu wa with that
okay but let's let's say in these situ
in this situation is
chris rock is will smith saying look i'm
sorry forgive me is he trying to make it
right or this is where it's just neutral
he's not doing anything
no it could be neutral and it can even
even uh what's his name will can be like
you know what
uh i forgive you uh chris because will
forgiving chris does not mean chris you
mean what is forgiving will yeah two
different things
can you say that last part again so i
said a will for giving chris
does not mandate chris to accept the
forgiveness and does not mandate that
christopher gives back will or for
whatever reason for the jokes well
actually maybe he should for that joke
maybe yeah but let's let's go deeper
here now because we all all of us back
to what you were saying that if you that
verse in the quran when god almighty is
saying look if you want me to forgive
you you forget others restraining your
anger forgiving you know the power of
that because we all have sins and if we
want if if you don't forgive for
instance and you're you're like you know
you're saying no no rot in hell and i'm
going to hold on to this until the day
of judgment look and allah and let's
let's say let's say that um abdullah
muhammad fatima will smith whoever the
case now that person is not just saying
you know look they're they're justifying
their actions or anything but let's say
that the person is really seeking
forgiveness you know they're trying to
make it right
and now they're going above and beyond
now as a believer will you be open up to
now your because you're holding on tight
you know let's say families getting
involved and families and you got your
your parents and in-laws whoever the
case you know and this is affecting them
too it's not just the one person so and
maybe you can give some live examples
where you got sister and sister fighting
brother and brother
and now you have the one sister doesn't
want to forgive her brother or the
brother doesn't want to forgive the
brother this is affecting mother this is
affecting father and one of them is
holding on so tight to this and the
other one is trying to make amends
trying to you know
keep the family together you know what
happens if you you keep you go for
option two or three but are you setting
yourself up tomorrow that you are going
to be put
you're going to be pulled out of line
and you also are going to be questioned
for some of the things many of the
things that you did against the law many
of the things that you did against
others talk about that
exactly you know um if i understood your
question correctly it's a scenario that
happens sometimes is when someone let's
say a wrongs b yeah then a wants to
apologize b please forgive me a beep i
promise i won't do it again but b is
just so stubborn and will never accept
the apology will never accept the
forgiveness and this way gets really
problematic you know the problem
he was telling me he says when there's
two people fighting
it's not be fitting
for three days to pass by
and no one says salaam
it's not it's not befitting and your
three your three days a deadline you
guys have to start saying
and the best of the two is one who
starts
tells the problem
the prophet of allah tells us there's a
day of the week in which allah
tells i forgive all people except to
mushrik the one who worships someone
other than allah
and the one who has a issue
between them and their brother and
sister a conflict of some sort
sometimes they are justified when it's
understandable right but let's be very
frank brother eddie sometimes they're
not justified
sometimes they're people actually you're
even embarrassed to say why they're not
talking to their brother and sister oh
why you guys are not talking about it i
don't want to bring it up sometimes
because it's not that big of a deal
sometimes we take it way too personal
sometimes it's the ego
but sometimes yes it's understandable
okay the question comes when do i not
forgive someone
the scot some of the scholars say you do
not forgive someone when you think
that your forgiveness to them will grow
them in their oppression
some people every time you forgive them
they just continue to get worse and
worse these people are not worth it
example can you give an example
uh sometimes let's say for example
someone is a criminal
all right every time he's out of prison
for as an example very generic right i
know there's some mental situations and
so on
the guy commits uh
let's say forget uh prison let's say i
work
someone doesn't show up to the meeting
oh i'm so sorry boss i will be early
next time next time he's not early he's
even later you forgive him so the
project is not doing well people are
being harmed this man can no longer be
forgiven because now it's harming you
society as a whole you cannot keep
forgiving that person you have to be
very wise
but that's not usually the common case
obviously it happens but the bottom line
your default is to seek to forgive and
that's what you aim for
what can happen now if you do you set
yourself up that because obviously if
that beautiful example you gave where
now allah tells you look i got your back
i got it taken care of you forgive and
don't you want allah to forgive you and
then allah can let you go on many things
but are you setting yourself up that now
you can end up being held for account on
many things because you are stubbornly
resistant to showing more mercy and
forgiving i see i see it it may depend
for example uh on the case of of rights
for example so
uh you know that's why there's these
three options and forgiveness to the
most part forgiveness is a second level
it's not an obligation
keep that in mind case by case situation
allah says in the quran
allah says let them forgive and let them
reconcile
do you not love for allah to forgive but
let me just tell you the story behind
that really quickly
because i believe that most of people
may allah protect us
whoever is watching whoever is hearing
us
i hope and i pray that you will never go
through the following
she's being accused of a major sin this
hadith
authentic narration
she's being accused of committing a
major sin so she's the daughter of the
greatest man after the prophet
and she is the wife of the prophet
and what is being said about her is a
major of a major sin may allah protect
so after all of this
the man was accusing her his name is mr
was the
cousin and the relative of
when it was shown that aisha was
innocent
says
i will never give the monthly allowance
to mr why is that because the prophet
abu bakr used to always give the
allowance because mr was a poor relative
she used to give him you know i'll help
you out financially so he said he talks
about my daughter
in a way that is false after all this
i'm never going to support him
financially because of that allah
revealed the verse and said
let not to those with money with power
and so on withhold their money and
support from one two three several
groups and mr being one of them the
relatives
when abu bakr he heard this verse then
allah ends that verse by saying do you
not want for allah to forgive you
then abu bakr says
he i love for allah to forgive me then
he said i will never stop giving him the
allowance back
now sometimes these moments eddie of
pain of you know what someone being you
know oppressed and so on and they have
the chance to hit back they have a
chance to file a lawsuit for example but
they say you know what
i want to forgive and you have that
power i want you to know that this is a
deal that allah does not give anyone
i know it sounds a bit strange but it's
a moment of pain that you have almost
like the world and you're in your hands
this is an opportunity that many people
do not get i got wronged
and i have the option to punish
and i have the option to forgive it's
like a gold it's a treasure in your hand
what will you do subhanallah
well it's a treasure well lies a
treasure
you're saying forgiveness is a treasure
absolutely it's a tragedy don't they
have don't they have a you have so many
studies also psychologists psychiatrists
talk about you know this being a
detriment to your health when you hold
on to working when you don't let things
go
100 absolute 100 there's a very famous
statement not too long ago i read it
it's a very famous one it says you
holding a grudge
is like drinking poison
hoping the other person dies
many times the grudge that we're holding
brother eddie the other person doesn't
even know about it doesn't even care he
moved on that that loser that person and
you're the one who's in pain
so you it's for your own sake that's why
i started the talk or life for your own
sake i'm not telling you all
you compare it in your talk i still
remember because you gave an analogy and
i want everybody to watch put your name
in youtube
and put forgive and forget and you talk
about you give an example of a book bag
and there's bricks in the book bag
absolutely absolutely i got a battery
right here
right
you know
you know whenever we have all that pain
we we fill up the bag and we have it we
carry it it's become so heavy on us
so every time you know someone annoyed
you you put it in that bag got a grudge
in that bag it becomes so heavy then you
have shoulder problems
back problems and who's suffering you're
suffering not the other person
so what i suggest is that you open up
that bag and you start getting rid of
the weights oh that's my cousin right
who heard me okay and that's my i don't
know on to make fun of you
right and he's let go and it becomes so
light and you can move on in life and
proceed and progress in life and i
encourage if we walk with upside down
bags
i just keep it open that's a good one
just keep it open
allah nothing is worth it by the end
yeah nothing there there's a there's a
hadith and muslim can you elaborate on
this hadith for the prophet
talks about the people's deeds being
presented before allah on mondays and
thursdays and then every slave of allah
is granted forgiveness
if he does not associate anything with
allah
but the person in whose heart there's
rancor against his brother will not be
pardoned
and with regard to them
it is said twice hold these two until
they reconcile you know can you go ahead
and elaborate on this what does this
mean towards the end hold them until
they reconcile
yes excellent so
every monday and thursday allah this is
for women this is for for all muslims
this is not just for men
men women all people
young old male female all people
so for this for the believers
they think oh i'm forgiven no there's
one more condition even if you say
and that condition is for you not to
have this mushachena this you know
hatred between your brothers and sisters
you have this severe unacceptable
dislike you have this issue the
animosity no allah says
uh let them hold on
and hat
until they reconcile so your forgiveness
on a hold wallahi imagine brotherhood
we give in charity
it's on hold
all that work it's on hold
because you are abandoning your brother
and sister for something that you don't
want to face allah with because you know
it's not that to that point may allah
forgive us and protect us i mean
yeah these are some really things you
know there's there's so many there's so
many uh ayahs verses in the quran
you know there's someone just like where
you're at with your deen i guess because
you have you've had people you've seen
stories of muslims actually they've gone
to court and the person who killed i'm
sure you've seen this pilot on news and
then someone went and killed i mean this
is just another level obviously
optional that's optional optional yeah
but you've had but then so you take that
example of someone a muslim in court
someone killed their son and then they
forgive them right
high level right and then but then you
have family feuds you just have people
then you have people
family you know families fighting family
over
you know
certain things you know and the list
goes on there's dramas of the day right
and they still it's ramadan has passed
a year ago another two years and then a
third year and it just keeps going and
they're still in the same place how do
we how do you motivate people to let go
of this rancor to move on to
two points i think of motivation
but before i start the motivation i want
to remind people that when you forgive
someone it doesn't mean you have to be
best friends again
that's something important people think
oh i have to be you know you know with
boys again we hang out always again not
necessarily
you know what you have your way out of
my way but
my heart inshallah i'll work on being
empty towards you
i will move on in life you move on in
life it doesn't mean you have to be best
friends so people get confused with that
no he says
we have dinner together as a family
especially his family and relatives it's
very sensitive
right because it's not a one-man show
brother eddie when you are having this
issue with a person let's say your two
sisters have an issue the whole family
will not have a thought here anymore
yeah
right and then and then you have to
realize that
and especially if this type of hate may
allah protect us especially if it's the
type of hate and grace like you're not
supposed to go to that person's house
just recently just recently actually in
two locations one in uh where was i in
massachusetts and the other one it was
in michigan
two different families from different
backgrounds and cultures they say my
father had a fight with his sister
and i want to say
mubarak make dua for my aunt
so i say okay text your aunt
then she says but if my dad knows he
will cut us off subhan allah
so now the bubble of the issue is no
longer limited to you and now you're
actually growing it and growing it which
is in an almost a pretty much
unacceptable way
i mean that now that's that's a whole
different issue now the branches of the
tree because families all connected now
the children seeing this exactly and now
this affecting them
but let's say you have a father or a
mother let's say the father saying to
the two sisters who are fighting they
say look my wishes and this is the
father's dying wish he's about to pass i
want to see you two together i want to
see you two make peace now you have
another element obedience to the parents
how do you reconcile how do you deal
with this
dying wish of the father and he wants
the two children you know the two
sisters for example to come together to
have iftar together with him right they
don't have to be best friends they don't
have to hang out all the time that's
their father's dying wish
subhanallah but they have real cases
like this people holding on right
they're holding on man you know when if
that sister that daughter in this
example that you gain if she accepts
she doesn't just get the reward of
allah's forgiveness but she gets the
reward of the greatest act of worship of
respecting parents
double dipped
double dip huh doubling the stock goes
up double absolutely
crypto
a little bit
much more
you know uh the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasabi says there are certain
deeds
that the
side effects positive or negative
are never as fast as being good to your
parents
you know how fast for example um someone
can make a commit a sin and they won't
see the effect of until let's say for
example five years later but there's
certain sins no you don't wait five
years right away it comes allah knows
exactly when and of those good deeds and
sins are the way we deal with our
parents in terms of respect and
disrespect and subhanallah sometimes the
reward comes right away so i pray to
allah i know there are examples like
that i know the example that
may allah forgive us
is that the mom tells the two brothers
the two of her sons
there's a story of a mom
very upset that two of her sons are not
talking to one another
okay and i try to talk to them and
they're trying to kind of loosen up like
i can't stand him whatever the case is
but why we what do we know brother eddie
from the past we have to hear stories of
the past when that father
dies
what happens they regret
after it's too late
dad has passed away i wish we reconciled
i wish we did that i wish we did this
it's too late
right but alhamdulillah the door of
allah of repentance is always open
insha'allah
but why wait
and that's why
sorry he said something very interesting
he says avoiding
a sin is better than repentance
right because there's a sin coming your
way don't say i'll commit it and i'll
see what happens if things go wrong i'll
make tawba that's so much work
just avoid it just avoid it it's a lot
easier this is a great example so you
have
the parents wishing for
the two brothers to reconcile but then
the parent
in this case was the father that died
and then you're in a state of regret for
the rest of your life rest of your life
right
now we have to also realize because we
have to also be fair sometimes the level
of abuse or oppression is at a level
that allah accepts that there's some
a boycott but that's an extreme
exception some people they use this
whole boycott let go cut off cancel very
loosely i'll be honest with you very
loosely sometimes
and when you hear the sahabah yes there
was there was some boycotting there was
kabhi ni malik was boycotted for 50
nights
15 nights but he returned back to allah
but that's not a common thing it's a
very extreme situation
but it's you it's you now to go ahead
and just like you go to a doctor you
know you go to a nutritionist for health
functional medicine whatever the case
for your body but now you're going to be
figuring these things out making your
own fatwas right you go to a qualified
spiritual doctor you go to a scholar in
islam and you talk about situation does
this justify that what i'm doing
separating my family instead of you
because if it's left to us shaytan's
going to keep you away from the scholars
keep you away you know from
knowledgeable people and you're just
going to go ahead and be in your little
bubble and make up your own uh answers
to those
the things that shaitan is putting in
your mind entertaining you right stay
away from this person keeping you away
from people of knowledge so how
important is that if you're in that
situation that you go around people you
you talk to people of knowledge you know
what i mean and you don't just make you
go [ __ ] you know you make up the fatwa
on your own yeah actually
that's a phenomenal point that you
brought up honestly this is a highlight
what you just said was a highlight
because many times we do not know unto
the most part the majority of the
stories that i have i know of i'm sure
there's other stories and i know
personally other specific stories but
the majority
it's not justifiable for people to cut
off each other i can repeat that
of two brothers two sisters two people
not talking to another is not
justifiable doesn't shaytan usually blow
that i mean blow it up like to you it's
like wow this is like you know someone
just uh kidnapped murdered my child and
you he's pumped it up so much but then
when you go and sit with someone you'd
be like man you're actually you're going
to extreme this is like you're yes
you're trying to see your point exactly
why is your point such a important
highlight because i i encourage every
person who's maybe watching us has an
ounce of faith
verify
verify be honest with yourself verify is
my scenario
one of those that it's okay to cut off
the other person just ask a qualified
imam scholar no local area just be
honest with yourself he tells you oh
your case is extreme i agree with you uh
actually file a lawsuit sure but just go
as brother eddie mentioned there's
people special in this and special on
that and special on this ask a person of
the deen who understands some guidelines
of the
brotherhood sisterhood what's right and
what's wrong
and have them assist you in your
situation within their law knowledge and
within their capacity 100
what do you do when somebody's kind of
resisting that they don't want a third
party involved or they're resisting
going and the other person you know it's
not just that black and white you have
situations where you have family
disputes and one has their side of the
story the other one has their other side
you know but now they're one is like
let's go let's go sit you find the
person let's go sit and let them
arbitrate let them tell us let them show
from the quran and sunnah but the other
one is like just
you know not uh not wanting to do that
see islam
really pushes towards reconcile
so show allah that you're trying show
allah that you're trying to study
situation
see what options that you have and is
strongly encouraged you know we have a
case brother eddie where uh a father of
some children is having an issue with
his ex-wife yeah his whole children are
in the middle
so they try and say let's bring an imam
he said i don't want to talk to no imam
let's bring okay someone okay from
another
from uh so and so individual no okay how
about a common person between us no okay
bring your own family i don't want this
stubbornness will not just go in vain
like that allah may hold that person
accountable
someone is trying to reconcile someone
is trying to fix things
you you should attempt to see what's the
matter how okay what offer things will
work out insha allah
and don't think that's the issue some
people think if i forgive
it will happen to me again that's not
that's shaytaan's tactic
if i forgive i will look weak
if i forgive i'm a loser no allah if you
forgive allah will honor you insha allah
if you forgive your status will be
respected by the whole family
insha'allah if you forgive your value
goes up in the sight of allah
will make you think it's low beneath you
beneath you know it's not
no it's not
that's the beauty of our deen it has
answers to all these issues problems
and that's our deficiency as human
beings we make mistakes we're sinners
right we sin by day and night but we
have a merciful lord and inshallah that
we can learn from these things and
other things before we conclude just
want to touch upon the
the the power of of of words you know it
reminds me of hadith where the prophet
saws had said that a slave of allah will
utter one word
and not think of the ramifications of it
and that person will end up falling so
i'm paraphrasing hadith yeah might fall
so deep in the hellfire but on the
contrary you know
utter one good word and allah can
elevate their status right can you talk
about that because sometimes in these
fights people are calling someone
monafic you know ex silent them from the
dean you know what i mean it means just
get have you seen these situations and
then they're not really
reflecting on the power the words and
you are forgetting that the angel on the
right is writing and you're going to be
held accountable in front of allah and
these words are heavy
excellent let me give you one example
he says
if someone tells their brother
if someone tells their brother
one of them has to be a catholic
this is this is that one word one word
oh you know what bro you're a kafir bro
so this means one of you has to be a
capper either you are right they are a
catholic or that they are not a catholic
so it goes against that person who said
it bounces back to you and bounces back
one word right
another one
i'll summarize it very quickly
someone tells another person who was
sinning
he's committing a major sin like
straight up clearly
visible to the people so the person
tells him you know what allah will never
forgive you you are never going to go to
heaven
the prophet says in authentic hadith the
angel of death comes takes the soul of
both people the one who was committing
the sin
and the one who told the other person
you're gonna go to hell
when they went to meet allah allah told
the sinner go to heaven due to my mercy
and the one who was judging or he's
going to hell
allah asks him did i share with you
unseen knowledge
allah's rebuking him did i tell did i
tell you a list of names who's going to
heaven and who's going to hell
allah does not wait for the response and
allah tells the angels take that person
and throw him into hell one word
oh he's going to hell bro for sure bro
he's going to go to jahannam
may allah protect him and that's your
brother and sister in the masjid
believing brother and sister in the
family may allah protect us that's why
the prophet sallallahu alaihi what did
he say
is
if one of you is angry remain silent
remain cool cool down a little bit
remains how many times brother eddie if
you send an email on gmail
okay i just sent you to your admin an
email they give me about 10 seconds you
want to undo the email
right it's always there undo about 10
seconds
and sometimes like undo because they
want to tell you sure you want to send
this
and we learned in the corporate world
given about 24 hours
i remember one one person i was so angry
i proved his personal life i was so
angry and because he messed up so bad i
wrote the email and said you know what
magic
just
keep the email in draft i kept it in
draft i did not believe the email
come the next day and read it and this
was personal i woke up next day went to
my draft i read it i'm like
alhamdulillah i did not send it well 24
hours later you were like
i didn't send it it would have been a
mess though i'm not the wrong wasn't on
him but he messed up i'm like you know
what let me address that differently
subhanallah but when is angry remains
silent that's
one of the keys
yeah
all right i want everyone again to watch
forgive and forget you type in majid
mahmud on
youtube it's something that i think
everyone should watch and in closing
tell us what else is ramadan it's the
month of mercy so many blessings
uh is it better now to let it go even
especially during ramadan and show that
mercy
during ramadan oh absolutely any
absolutely eddie you said is it
especially in ramadan of course
because in ramadan
how long does it take two three hours
in ramadan the prophet says authentic
hadith is equal to hajj
ramadan
so that means that good deeds in ramadan
are multiplied in ways that no one can
imagine
so imagine you choose this month and
what a great month it is to choose to
say you know what
ramadan 2022
a new page
that person is forgiven because the next
next time that person says
you love to forgive you are the most
forgiving so please forgive me the
greatest dua in ramadan
you know inshallah allah will forgive
and allah will accept because of what
you did and forgiveness
so you can bank on that let's say you
don't know you did some major sin some
major crimes with allah just just
imagine like you're wanted by the fbi by
the cia or the sheriff you know to come
to get you doug the bounty hunter
whatever the case but now because you
showed this mercy and forgiveness you
did such now that's like a jail get out
of jail free car for some of the major
crimes
you can you can bank on this
this was heavy on me now you go ahead
and for the sake of family for the sake
of you know unity
you you forgave you can go ahead and use
this for allah to forgive you for many
of the crimes you've done
absolutely
that person got an opportunity that
maybe most people on the earth will
never get
it's it's a jackpot it's it's in your
hand how will you use why would you not
take that why would you not take that
that's why the two ways the two the two
steps about you know being able to
forgive number one
realize the lowliness of this dunya this
duny is not worth a penny no no
literally not worth the pain it's not
informative
it's not an exaggeration because the
prophet
he passed by a dead goat
so then he told the sahaba who would
like to have this dead goat for him
and that goat was dead and flies and the
ear was cut off
so the prophet said who would take it
for one dirham so the sahaba said ya
rasulullah we will not take it even if
it was for free wow
now the prophet said well
he didn't he does not say well but he's
emphasizing
he says i swear to god the value of this
world is lesser than the value of this
dead filthy goat is to you
subhanallah and we're killing over each
other and we're cutting each other it's
not worth it so think of the dunya being
lowly and think of the reward being high
these two is what will help you
inshallah dunya is cheap
is expensive
subhanallah and the more the more you
put jannah you more you put the
in front of you the more the dunya
becomes smaller you see absolutely the
problems of the dunya
yeah
one different gender the prophet
the one who's watching me right now may
have the most miserable life
may have the most difficult life i share
with you is one hadith the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam says
a man or a woman who has been suffering
the worst suffering the worst
individual's lifestyle ever pain
struggle sickness death in the family no
money you name it the whole package
will be dipped one dip in general one
dip like a dairy queen no dairy queen
the brother eddie the ice cream one dip
then that person will be asked have you
ever seen any hardship in your life
that person will not say yes but i don't
care that person will say i don't know
what you're talking about
well they even recognize like what do
you mean and that's the most miserable
person one tip in jannah
subhanallah so the one was being hurt
and you have the chance to retaliate
why not forgive
it just a side note it had me thinking
real situation where you had people who
are breaking ties of kinship and they
were keeping this per they weren't
reconciling and next things you saw
allah knows best but in their own home
you saw discord con also you have it
affecting you in ways that it can come
to you in other ways where now affects
your own children and you see like wow
can this be a ramification of sometimes
these things that we're we're
not letting go of
that that especially is possible when
the one is cutting off for such reasons
and such issues and growing it
out of proportion and it's not banning
from this person to visit that person
because that person is angry at me and
you make your circle bigger and so even
just let's think about as you mentioned
brother eddie
let the kids learn from the parents
right because you tell your two kids hey
forgive your brother who took your
crayon
so you forgive your brother who took
your car
wow so this so this is like you know we
often give the example like you know
smoking you're smoking tell your kid not
to smoke but you're smoking but now take
it to a higher level you're not
forgiving but you're telling your kid to
forgive it's i mean how are they
supposed to learn from you yeah so so
all these things that we're saying dunya
is being cheap
as being rewarding let your kids learn
from you your parents will be happy it's
a bundle of reward and benefit the only
allah is aware of and there's a story of
one of the scholars
he went to uh someone who gave and he
gave him a gift
he said what's the gift for he said i
heard that you were back biting me
right so though it's painful
but he said now i know it's an
opportunity for me to take good deeds
as an example right so the point being
here the moral of the story is that
how you're able to see moments of pain
as moments of gain
see moments of pain as moments of gain
yes so it's a painful moment but you can
gain so much out of it
and you don't want to be the one like
you said earlier who's drinking poison
waiting for the other person to die like
that's like holding on to that grudge
yes not forgiving that's not what
subhanallah all right any uh anything
else you want to leave us with before we
conclude
um
what's today's date
last piece of advice
for those people now you got they're
tuning in they're like man i just hate
these are let's say uh blood brothers
blood sisters and they're they got
they're sitting now now they're
opportunity you know what i mean uh they
shook off shaytan they might have just
finished prayer and now they're
listening what advice do you do you have
for him
a man goes to allah subhanahu wa on a
day of judgment
and he sees another person the other
person wronged them
so allah tells the person that they can
basically take the good deeds because of
the wronging
so the man who did the wrong says i
don't have good deeds to give you i ran
out
so then allah shows a mansion a palace a
place in paradise for the one who was
wronged
he says look at this
so the one who's wrong says
to which prophet does this paradise
belong to
then allah says
who can afford it is one who gets it
so the man says and who in the world can
afford it he said you can afford it is
it me i can afford this palace this
beautiful jannah he said he said how you
allah by your forgiving your brother
allah
it's something that you would think only
for profits but you can afford it by
forgiving that man or that woman
so don't lose that offer and getting
this
brother eddie if this was the offer in
then what's the offer if it was done in
dunya
right
early bird early bird prices now
we need these heart softeners you know
the the dunya a lot of times the hearts
become hard and yeah they need to be
soft this is the month inshallah i pray
to allah whoever is watching whoever is
watching may allah ease our hearts may
allah
may allah make us focus keep our eyes on
the prize
and forgive in hopes that allah will
forgive us
and i remember i'll end with this
statement
one of the scholars some says
regardless
he was wrong so bad
and he made a deal with allah
allah that person who
wronged me
i forgive them so you allah please
forgive me he's a smart he's a genius
oh allah i forgive that you see how he
started ya allah forgive that person so
ya allah would you forgive me
just go to allah and remember the sins
that you have and know that one of the
strongest ways to get it erased is by
forgiving someone else for what they've
done may allah forgive us
thank you very much
again may allah bless you
and that was some great advice so what
should will smith and chris rock do well
the first thing is because on a day of
judgment they're going to have bigger
problems to worry about
i think they should be first and
foremost
seeking to know what is the true purpose
of life and who best to tell us than the
creator of life the creator of humanity
the one who sent the prophets and
messengers who warned of the day of
judgment paradise in the hellfire and
called people they all called people the
last and final messenger sent to mankind
prophet muhammad whose brother to jesus
moses abraham all the messengers they
came with the same message
of calling humanity to worship one and
only one god the creator alone not his
creation to be morally upright and we
have all that encompassed in
islam submission to the will of god
almighty
and
then everything else will fall in place
so we'll have bigger problems to worry
about but for us now those who are
living islam forgiveness is a key you
don't want to be that person who's
drinking poison waiting for the other
person to die you don't want to be
raising your hands
and your dual is not getting accepted
because now you are
cutting off ties of kinship you're
disobeying your parents and you're going
above and beyond for revenge hatred is
eating away at your heart
and it's gonna be something that affects
not only you but your family
and all those down the line but you have
a chance now
to see the value as your beautiful
example what's the value of this dunya
at the end of the day what is it worth
so work together work out the problems
do it for the sake of allah that
beautiful dua allah
i forgive them so forgive me because
that's the ultimate purpose is to get
the mercy and forgiveness from allah the
creator that happens in earth and how
we're going to get that forgiveness if
we're not being those who have mercy on
others and we're also looking at the
bigger picture and we're being forgiving
all right so that's it all right
hopefully uh this is a benefit we'll see
you next time subscribe if you haven't
already support us
here on the dean show until then peace
be with you assalamu alaikum cannot
leave without giving you a gift if you
are not yet muslim and you're tuning in
to see what these muslims are talking
about and you'd like a free copy of the
quran go and visit the deenshow.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you assalamu
alaikum and if you like this episode of
the dean show like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum